we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to this collar hi David I just
wanted to thank you for saying nunez
correctly whenever I was talking about
congressman you know um some journalists
joy Reid and David Ignatius from the
Washington Post all these people are
calling him unions which implies that
he's Latino Mexican or Spanish and it's
his last name is Portuguese so yeah
anyway I just wanted to thank you for
saying that properly that's right yeah
Pat and I had a conversation about this
because pat was saying Nunez and I
explained to Pat that when it's a
regular N and an S on the end those
names that might sound like they are
Latino last names are actually
Portuguese so Rodriguez but with an S on
the end which some Portuguese in the
Boston area say Rodricks that's
Portuguese and if you have Z and and
that that would mean yes so I am acutely
aware of that and making every effort
and now you are too pat right to
pronounce it correctly right and I got
to point out that it could have been
worse i could have said Nunes it would
be an even more American pronunciation
and far worse i would say yes it would
on the bonus show today i will follow up
about what is going on with the YouTube
advertiser boycott we will talk about a
Texas man who deliberately swelled
swerved into motorcyclists being
sentenced to 15 years in prison and Jeb
Bush is now warning that robots taking
American jobs is not science fiction you
know that our current president would
call that low energy but Jeb Bush is
absolutely right and we're going to dig
into those issues and more on today's
bonus show david pakman.com slash
membership is how you sign up for the
bonus show we have a coupon code I voted
17 we have to replace a 40-percent
revenue reduction to the show as a
result of the YouTube advertiser boycott
this is just Matt and if you value the
show if you want the show to continue on
interrupted please sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership one membership can make up
for
probably 50 youtube viewers comparing
the fraction of a penny that we used to
get when someone watched an ad on
youtube compared to paying three or four
bucks a month for membership which is
exactly what you pay if you use the
coupon code I voted 17 so sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership more
about everything that's going on on the
bonus show today